breaking just moments ago in afghanistan
an order issued by the u.s state
department it reads quote
because of security threats outside the
gates of kabul airport we are advising
u.s citizens to avoid traveling to the
airport and to avoid airport gates at
this time
u.s citizens who are at the abbey gate
east gate or north gate now should leave
immediately
here now eric trump executive vp of the
trump organization that just tells me
there's imminent danger
eric what's your reaction
jesse what are these people supposed to
do they got to get out of the country
they got to get home right i mean this
president is a national embarrassment a
week ago the taliban they were riding
around on scooters on mopeds now they're
flying our blackhawk helicopters with
our night vision glasses with us sniper
rifles it's absolutely disgusting the
incompetence of this administration the
incompetence of this president
you know our family myself included my
father every single day we fought for
this country so this nonsense wouldn't
happen i was on the campaign trail you
know this very well every single day for
a year
telling people how incompetent this
person is and honestly jesse he's
exceeded every expectation i could have
possibly had
you know your father was known for
bringing hostages back he negotiated
dozens and dozens of releases of
hostages that had been stranded overseas
for many many years even featured that
at the republican national convention
never leave a man behind just doesn't
seem to be the priority of the bide
administration they've chosen to leave
men and women behind that's been a
choice
they're not extending the deadline
they're actually taking orders from the
taliban instead of killing the taliban
it just seems like
the exact opposite of what we had before
it's because my father could make it up
a flight of stairs he could make it onto
air force one without falling down the
stairs right you know people had respect
for my father you know he put people in
line when he he had to that's what the
commander-in-chief needs to do instead
joe biden's literally kneeling in front
of wnba teams get off your knees joe
biden stand up and actually show the
world some leadership as as the
commander-in-chief you know the reason
my father got hostages back from all
over the world was he didn't put up with
nonsense you know if you guys are going
to act like animals we're going to treat
you like animals we're going to drop a
moab on your head soleimani we're going
to take you out with a you know with a
reaper drone and he showed the world
that he didn't play around that's the
exact opposite of joe biden what's he
doing he's at camp david for the last
two weeks he hasn't showed his face he's
running around jesse yes i called all
the g7 leaders and all the g7 leaders
are like we haven't heard from this guy
i mean he is nowhere to be found where
where is the vice president during all
of this where
where is the leadership i mean
they totally abandoned the world we lost
6 000 troops 6 000 meeting troops and
contractors in afghanistan we spent two
trillion dollars there and in seven days
we lose the country we abandon all our
interpreters all our
allies who fought by our sides and now
they're driving up armored humvees they
have our drones they have our blackhawk
helicopters they've got our best rifles
they've got our m16s and everything else
i mean they have our body armor you see
these guys marching around kabul in our
body armor are we out of our damn minds
80 billion 80 billion dollars after
losing 6 000 troops they have 80 billion
dollars of u.s military equipment i mean
we couldn't possibly be this incompetent
i mean
we are because he is but it's it's it's
it's just
it's devastating jesse to me as a you
know a guy who fought for this country
as hard as we did and saw the great
things my father did for this nation how
much backbone he put into the u.s
military and
how much you know our adversaries around
the world respected us because we didn't
play games and uh you know this guy's
flushing the reputation of the united
states of america down the toilet he is
and he's getting rid of all the
successful things
that your father had done the pipelines
the border afghanistan usually you throw
out the bad stuff he's throwing out the
stuff that works makes no sense can't
really understand it because he doesn't
even take questions he just reads off a
prompter all right eric trump we gotta
run very
tenuous situation at the airport in
kabul and we're gonna bring you the
latest thank you so much eric
thanks jesse hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else